Kim Kardashian and Kendall Jenner slam
Caitlyn's new memoir that's insane
[Music]
on this Sunday's episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians Kim and Kendall
take aim at the former Olympians book
the secrets of my life and she goes
around dissing the Kardashians but it's
like those are the kids that you raised
if you have a problem with them you
raised them that makes no sense to me
that she would go around bashing like us
for no reason in the memoir Caitlyn
claims that her now ex-wife Kris had
been hoarding money for years
something Kris adamantly denies she said
I didn't see a dime of my money
she was insinuating that like mom took
the check and pocketed it and like had
this huge savings the money wasn't going
in mom's pocket him goes on to explain
how Caitlyn quote discredits the family
matriarch she's so angry at mom like for
no reason it was like I didn't speak to
my sister because of Kris I didn't see
my kids because of Kris like grow up and
say I didn't call my kids
you